- [Dani] Hi everyone.
Great people doing a
code talk after lunch.
And (chuckles)
my name is Dani, I'm
a solutions architect.
I'm focused on GenAI.
I work in the Amazon Bedrock team,
focusing on knowledge
base and AgentCore memory.
And I'm here today with Akarsha.
Akarsha, do you wanna?
- [Akarsha] Hi, everyone.
My name is Akarsha Sehwag,
I'm a GenAI data scientist
with AgentCore memory team.
- [Dani] Yep.
So today, let me just go back a second,
but we're gonna be talking,
we're gonna be doing a code talk.
So it's gonna be basically
us going through some code.
So it's gonna be like a level 400 session.
So we'll go, we'll dive deep
into the details of the,
you know, different APIs
and the code that we're
gonna be using today.
So we're gonna be diving deep
into agentic RAG systems, right?
So we'll just start out,
we'll set the layers to the foundation,
let's talk about what agentic RAG is,
and then we'll see what
we are building today.
And then I promise I'll
go out of the slides
and go into the code, right?
I won't be an hour with slides.
And at the end we'll
give you some resources
that we put together to get started.
So let's start with the basics.
Retrieval-Augmented Generation.
I hope everyone in the
room has heard about this.
We've been talking about this
for the past two or three years.
So I just wanna go quickly over
what retrieval-augmented-generation
is, right?
Or how the workflow goes.
The very, very high level,
we have our query that we
send into our model, right?
But before we send that into a model,
we're gonna augment that query, right?
We're gonna give it
additional information.
This can come from our, you
know, internal data sources.
So you just wanna provide
external information to the model
so it doesn't hallucinate,
and then it will have the
full context to, you know,
generate an answer and
give you back the response.
But, Akarsha, is that correct or not?
- [Akarsha] I mean,
it's partially correct.
- Yeah.
- So,
when we think about agents, right?
We have the LLM that has
a lot of capabilities,
but agents themselves are
fundamentally stateless.
So all we can provide from
our side to make them better,
to make them smarter,
is in this retrieval,
in this RAG component.
So today, we don't just consider RAG
to be retrieving from a
knowledge base or a data source,
we talk about more in a generalized way,
which is called context.
So today you must have heard these,
this new term popping up everywhere,
which is called context engineering.
So essentially what it
does, and what it means is
we are curating our context
in a way that we are providing
very precise information
that the agent needs to give smart
and more accurate responses, right?
So that includes information
from the documents,
so the traditional RAG component.
Then it also includes curating our tools.
So figuring out which
tools to are relevant
for this current query
or this current use case.
So finalizing those
and also making sure
that whatever information
we have provided in those
tools is very accurate
for the agent to know when to use it.
And then we have the memory component.
So memory component is
where we are providing it
with more information about the user
to make it more personalized,
to make the experience
for the user much better, right?
So that's where the
memory component comes in.
And all of this combined is
what defines the context.
- [Dani] Yeah, that
sounds right. (chuckles)
So now we have, then we have,
now we, you know, we have
all this context coming in
and we have a new way
of retrieving our information, right?
So we have our query,
we have a retrieval that retrieve we can,
you know, import information
from different sources
as Akarsha just mentioned.
Then we will augment that query
and then the model will decide,
"hey, am I able to answer
with the information I retrieve it,
do I have to go back again and, you know,
look for a bit more information?"
If not, we can get back the response.
(coughs) Apologies.
So this is agentic RAG at a
high level, (coughs) apologies.
So what are we building today, okay?
Why are we here today?
We are gonna be building
an event agent, okay?
As I imagine you have your AWS
event application right now.
And at the bottom there was a,
I saw before there was a
small text box which said,
so ask me something or
something like that, right?
And you'll have your common,
you'll have your common agent now
or your common chatbot implemented
into all of these applications.
But we want to not only be able
to search across the
sessions informations,
but we want to deliver truly
hyper personalized experience
to our users, right?
So I can say, hey, what
sessions do you recommend me?
And I expect, or we normally
expect nowadays these agents
to have information about this, right?
Remember some stuff about this
and being able to recommend the stuff
based on our preferences, right?
Or questions like, which
session did we talk
about last time, right?
Having some kind of history
or what sessions are
there on Monday, right?
These kind of common event
questions that show up.
And if you don't ask the app,
you ask someone who is,
who's there to help.
We want to have it all in a single place.
So we are gonna be building
this AWSome event agent, okay?
And this is gonna be basically an agent
that has two capabilities.
So our users are gonna be able
to interact with our agent,
and that agent is gonna
be able to do two things.
One of them is, as I mentioned before,
retrieve session information
from a knowledge base.
And secondly, it's gonna be able to store
and retrieve the conversation
history that we had, right?
And it's gonna be able to
learn from our conversation,
our user preferences.
Okay, so yeah, I think that's
enough slides at the moment.
Let me go and show you all this
looks from a code perspective.
If there are any questions,
put your hand up.
It's a small room today.
We'll try to answer the questions along.
If not, we are happy to
answer the questions,
so when we are outside, right? Cool.
So I'll go through the,
I've got the notebook ready
with this event agent.
We'll make this available
this week in our repo
for AgentCore samples.
We'll give you the
resources for that later.
So just bear with me
and let's figure out
what's going on in this notebook, okay?
So can everyone see this, right?
Let me just go to the text
and see if we need to make
it a bit bigger or not.
- [Akarsha] Yeah, okay. Good.
- Good?
- Yeah.
- [Dani] I don't see anything 'cause
I've got this big lights here. (laughs)
But anyway, so this was
the same slide that before.
This is the high level picture of
what we are building today.
And we are gonna go through
what we call different chapters
and it's gonna be creating the agent.
We create the simple agent,
we create the knowledge base,
that's where the session information is.
We create the memory for agent
to have that persistence,
and then we are gonna see how
we can move this to production
and do it in a secure way
using AgentCore runtime
or AgentCore identity.
So if I start here with my notebook,
pretty simple, just
installing some dependencies
I need this to work with.
I'll import some libraries that I need
for the notebook to work
and important things here
is that I'm gonna be using
Claude Haiku 4.5.
I'm gonna be using Amazon
Titan text embedding v2
for my knowledge base, and I'll
talk about that a bit later.
I just want you to understand
what's going on here.
I'm just setting those
and creating a unique idea
to have unique resources, okay?
Pretty simple.
For every code, I will
show you the outputs.
It makes much more sense.
So let's start with the agent.
What are we going to, yeah,
- [Audience Member] what is
it like the database here?
- [Dani] Sorry, the...
- [Akarsha] We'll get to that.
- [Dani] Yeah, give me one
chapter and I'll get to that.
So, let's start with the agent, right?
Let's start with the most simple step.
We are gonna be building
a simple agent, right?
And that agent is gonna have a context.
And that context is just gonna be,
you are an intelligent
event assistant, right?
So I'm gonna be using Strands Agents,
Akarsha, did use any
other framework here, or?
- [Akarsha] You can use
any framework you want.
So you can use LangGraph,
LangChain, CrewAI,
any framework that you're currently using.
We use Strands Agents
because it makes it very easy for us
to build agents and Strands Agents is a,
I would say fairly new framework
that has been out in the market.
It's an open source
framework that allows us
to leverage the capabilities
of the model itself,
to be able to plan, to take actions
and also to revisit whatever has occurred,
if it actually achieves the goal or not,
to be able to reflect on that.
- [Dani] Okay, then I'll
go with Strands. (chuckles)
So what do I need to do to
create my agent with Strands?
I just create, I just
import my agent class
and then I import my model class.
I'm gonna be using model,
which is available in Amazon Bedrock,
that's the Haiku 4.5, right?
And to create an agent
with Strands Agents,
is just simple as, let me
just get my pointer out here.
I'm gonna create my simple agent.
This is gonna be my class
that I brought before.
I'm gonna be defining a model,
the model that's underneath this agent,
and I'm gonna be giving
it a system from, right?
So I'm gonna give it a bit of context
on what it's supposed to be doing.
So it's simple as saying,
hey, you are an intelligent
event assistant, okay?
Simple as that.
You create your first
agent, one line of code,
if I take out the white space.
So when I go and interact with this agent,
I'll say, "Hey, simple agent,
which is a good session
to learn about security
and AI agents, right?"
And we see that the agent will respond,
"Hey, I don't have enough information
about specific sessions or
events in your current context."
And that makes completely sense
because I haven't told
it I'm at (indistinct)
I haven't given any
information about the sessions.
It's just a blank agent
and it's just, you know, using the model
on the hood with the information
that it's been trained on.
So that's completely normal, right?
So how do we start giving
context to our agent?
So one way is via knowledge base, right?
And with knowledge base,
what we're gonna be doing
is we are gonna be
providing the re:Invent.
So in this case,
I'm using the re:Invent 2024 sessions
I found around, (chuckles)
and I'm gonna be providing
that to agent. okay?
So for anyone who
doesn't know in the room,
Amazon Bedrock Knowledge
Base is a fully managed
service inside the Amazon Bedrock.
And it helps you create
fully managed workflows
for RAG, right?
So we are gonna be able
to create a knowledge base
where we are gonna say,
we're gonna be able to
define our data source layer
and a data storage layer, right?
So when I'm talking
about data source layer,
I have right now, NGA,
we have two available data connectors.
So I can basically
bring in my data from S3
or I can directly send in the information
into the Bedrock knowledge base.
I have four different
chunking strategies, right?
So when we are talking about RAG,
the flow is normally
you have your documents,
you get those documents
and you parse them to understand
what's inside those documents, right?
And once you have that, you're
gonna split those documents
into smaller chunks, okay?
Then using an embedding model,
we are gonna transform
those chunks into vectors
and those vectors end up in
a vector database, right?
Pretty simple RAG knowledge base helps you
with this whole process
in a managed way, right?
You only have to configure
where your data is coming from,
what kind of chunking
strategy you want to use,
what kind of parsing
and then define what
embedding model I'm using
and the underlying vector store, okay?
So all that information is gonna end up
in my knowledge base, and
then I can use retrieve API
to retrieve the chunks.
So basically doing a semantic search
against the vector database,
or I can use retrieve and generate,
which will combine that process
of retrieve my chunks
and automatically sending it
to the foundation model, right?
And getting back a response.
So I have those two options there.
So what am I gonna be doing?
I'm gonna be creating a tool for my agent
and that tool is gonna be able
to call knowledge base, okay?
So here my code, I will, let me see,
I'm going with time, I'm going good.
What I'll do is these are the steps
that I'm gonna go through.
I'm gonna download my 2024 session data.
I'm gonna create my S3 bucket.
That's where those
documents are gonna end up.
And I'm gonna upload them.
I'm gonna create an S3 vector store index.
So for this use case, I'm gonna
be using S3 vectors, right?
This is a fairly new capability from S3,
which gives support for
vector storage, okay?
Then I'm gonna go and
create my knowledge base
and do the ingestion job, okay?
Finally, I will test that knowledge base
and final, then I will create
that tool for the agent
to consume.
So pretty simple steps here.
I don't want to spend
too much time on this.
The other one is more catchy I think.
But basically here,
first is what I'm doing
is I'm basically
downloading my data, right?
I'm downloading,
it's basically a single file
which contains information
about 583, if I remember
correctly, sessions.
- 88.
- Exactly.
It downloads that file.
I am just understanding
what's going on on that file.
Then I'll prepare those documents.
So instead of having a single file,
I'm gonna split it 580 different files,
which will go into the knowledge base.
So that's just basically
what I'm doing here, right?
I'm creating my directory
and I will split that single file
into multiple files, okay?
Pretty, pretty simple.
So I'm gonna be preparing those documents,
as you can see here,
creating those 500 documents
and putting it into a folder.
Then what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna send those
documents to my S3 bucket, okay.
So here I'm just creating my S3 bucket.
I'm gonna give it a unique name,
that's where I'm gonna
be sending my files to.
And once I have created that bucket
I will upload the documents, right?
Using, in this case,
we're using (indistinct)
to send the documents to the bucket.
Pretty, pretty simple.
Right, so as you can see
here, I'm creating my bucket
and then I'm uploading all the files.
This took like six, this
took one minute, it's okay.
It wasn't that much.
Next, what do I need to do?
I need to create my IAM role
for my knowledge base, right?
My knowledge base needs
access to an embedding model
and it needs access to
the S3 bucket, right?
In order to do all of its tasks.
So I'm just creating a simple IAM role
where I'm gonna be creating it
and I'll use it later, okay?
All of this, we can do it via code,
which what I'm doing right now,
but you can also do this
via the console, right?
Maybe a bit nicer, but
I have my notebook here.
So just creating my
knowledge base role there.
Pretty simple.
And then I go and create
my S3 vector store
and index, right?
These is where knowledge base
is gonna do the whole ingestion job
and the resulting vectors from
the chunks that we created,
they're gonna end up in
that vector store, okay?
And as it's as simple as
saying, hey, S3 vectors,
I'm using the (indistinct)
clients for s3vectors,
create the vector bucket
and I give it the name, easy.
And then I go and create
vector index. Okay?
So here in the vector index,
what I'm saying is I'm
gonna give it, you know,
where it's supposed to
be, that index in that,
in the vector bucket I created before,
I'm gonna give it an index name
and I'm gonna give it a dimension, right?
And this dimension that I'm
using here, which is 1024,
I'm stating that there
because that's what tightening
embeddings V2 is gonna be
giving us back when we do that comparison
from text to embeddings, right?
Then we set other topics like
distance metric, data type,
and some metadata configuration, okay?
So here we just creating our
S3 vector store and index.
As you can see here, we get
an ARN for both of them.
And now I can go ahead and
create my knowledge base. Okay?
So I'm creating my knowledge
base, simple API call,
I'm creating my knowledge base
here, use my pointer better.
I'm creating my knowledge base,
giving it the name and
giving it a description.
So it's my AWS re:Invent
2024 sessions knowledge base
and giving it the role
that I created before.
And then I'm filling in the configuration
for that knowledge base, right?
So basically here what I'm doing is,
I'm saying you're gonna be using
the Titan text V2 embedding models
that I defined at the
start of the session.
And this is the configuration
for that embedding model, okay?
Here's the 1024 that I used
before for my index, okay?
And then for my storage configuration,
it's gonna be using that index
store that I set up before.
Pretty simple. (chuckles)
Any questions up to here?
I explained it very good,
or I confused you even more.
Okay, I'll take it as the first one.
So I just created my knowledge base
and now I can go ahead
and import and you know,
ingest the data from S3, right?
So I created my knowledge base
and I'll go and ingest my data
and create my knowledge source.
It's an S3 type, knowledge source,
data source, sorry,
with my S3 configuration
and giving it my bucket name.
And here I'm giving the
chunking configuration.
I'm using a fixed size strategy.
We have fixed size, we have no chunking.
We can do semantic chunking,
we can do hierarchical chunking.
You can even bring your own lambda
to do your own chunking
configuration, right?
So there's quite a lot
of flexibility there
depending on your use case, okay?
But in this case, pretty simple.
Fixed size max 300 tokens
and then 20% overlap.
20 overlap percentage, right?
So from there I can go and
start ingesting my data
and I'll wait for that to finish.
That took me around two
minutes, that's good.
It processed my 583 files
and I can go and ahead
and test my knowledge
base retrieval, right?
So if I ask a question, "Hey,
what other sessions about
generative AI and security,"
I will go and use the retrieve API,
which I mentioned before.
So I'm just retrieving the chunks,
I'm just doing a semantic search
and it will give me back the
three most relevant results
for that query, right?
So if I ask that question, it'll say,
"Hey, I found these three results."
And these are the three
chunks it got back, right?
These three sessions that I have here.
Okay, pretty simple.
I just created knowledge
base, ingested my data
and I did that all programmatically.
Now fun bit, I'm gonna create
my knowledge based search tool
and this is what the
agent is gonna be using.
So how tool works with Strands
is that you're gonna take your Python code
with your, you know, typical function
and you're going to put in
here this tool decorator, okay?
And with that tool decorator,
then you can pass it on to the agent
and the agent will make use of that tool.
So the nice thing about this tool
is that I'm gonna be
passing in description
and that's what the agent
is gonna first read, right?
And see if it needs to
use that tool or not
for the task it need.
So as you can see here, I'm saying,
hey, this is a tool to
search re:Invent sessions
from a knowledge base
using semantic search.
Use this tool whenever a user asks
for recommendation about
re:Invent sessions, right?
And I can pass in a query
and max results, right?
And this is just a plain
API called to bedrock
and knowledge base,
which is retrieve, okay?
And I'm passing in my knowledge base ID,
my retrieval query and a
retrieval configuration, okay?
So with that I have my knowledge
base search tool created
and I think Akarsha you
can take it on from here.
Yeah.
- [Akarsha] Okay,
so we have one of the
competence of the agentic RAG
that we were talking about.
We have that ready.
And we have that ready
for consumption as well
because you have created
it as a tool, right?
So one key difference why you
would use something as a tool
would be when you want
the agent to decide,
you want to have it,
the flexibility to choose
when does it want to call it,
when does it feel it's relevant to call
the knowledge base, right?
So that's when we are using the tool.
We could take another
approach with the hooks.
This is what we are gonna
see a bit later here,
but it's dependent on how dynamic
or how deterministic do you want it to be.
You would choose one or the other.
So now let's add the second component
of context into our agent.
So let's look at the memory, right?
So what memory does to persist
our agent conversation,
so we added the RAG so far
with some generic information, right?
Now, we are adding memory
to have more personalized
context about the users.
So how that works is our users,
when they're interacting with the agent,
they have this conversation
that they build up over time, right?
So that information goes
into the AgentCore Memory
as events.
So those events we term
as short-term memory,
yeah.
Those events we send
into short-term memory
which stores those events
into a data store as raw
conversational messages.
Now those messages based
on how you configure it,
so you can choose to have
more extracted insights
from those events and
say that for example,
hey I wanna create user
preferences strategy.
So I want to extract from all
the conversations you've had,
I wanna extract user preferences
from that conversation.
Or you can choose something
between semantic or summary.
So these are some predefined strategies
that we have in AgentCore Memory
or you can customize those as well.
So you can either customize the prompts
of those inbuilt strategies
or create a completely
new pipeline of your own.
So that's completely dependent on you.
- [Dani] Yeah, and if I
can just add onto that
just for a second, just to
give you a use case, right?
We have our agent, which
we are speaking with
for a whole week.
If I am stacking up the
conversation history of over week
and sending it over to the agent
and for the LLM to process,
whoever's paying for the
bill is not gonna be happy
because you have this really big context
and it's gonna be affecting the price.
'cause it's a huge context.
It's gonna be affecting the latency
because you know, it's got to process more
and then it can even have
problems with accuracy, right?
If I've got this huge
amount of information
I have to process,
it should be better
if it was smaller, right?
So instead of taking that big context
and passing it onto the
agent, it makes more sense
to extract what's actually important
from that conversation, right?
And that's where the long term comes in,
where you're defining, hey,
from all of these messages
that are going in between
my users and my agent,
I want to extract specific things, right?
And extract user
preferences, semantic facts,
session summaries, or you can
even find your own, you know,
workflow of what you wanna extract.
And I shut up with that. (chuckles)
- Yeah.
- And so question here.
- For the short memory,
what use an editing
decide what is relevant
based on the context or?
- [Akarsha] For the short-term memory,
you store deterministically,
you send those messages
in the AgentCore Memory.
So they're-
- Which ones do I send?
Have a conversation (faintly speaks).
- [Akarsha] Ideally you send all of them,
- [Audience Member] I just
(faintly speaks), you can repeat
the voice (faintly speaks).
- Oh yeah.
- Okay. Sorry.
Sorry about that. Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So is this based
on (faintly speaks) of user,
this short-term core memory
has (faintly speaks).
- [Akarsha] So AgentCore Memory
is defining the separation
based on the actor ID,
the session ID and the memory ID.
So when you're creating a memory,
it takes in two more identifiers from you,
which is the actor ID and the session ID.
So the actor is usually the
user, but it doesn't have to be.
So it takes in a string that defines
who do these memories belong to, right?
So it can be the agent,
it can be a project,
it can be a team,
it can be a combination of these.
You have flexibility
of what you wanna define in that actor ID
and same for session ID,
but those would be the identifiers
based on which it'll separate the memories
one from the other.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I want, for example,
take the feedback that user has given
the sessions that they
have attended, the survey.
- Yeah.
- We hope for this session,
it's a five star, just saying. (chuckles)
- [Audience Member] So give
recommendations of the next day
when they ask, would that be a memory?
Would there be another tool?
- [Akarsha] That should
be stored in the memory?
That should be in the memory. Yes.
- [Audience Member] So customer,
like what we wanna to store?
- We will, we-
- Yeah, we'll get to that.
- [Akarsha] We will look at the code.
So I think code should
clarify how to use it,
but this is just more on the
conceptual level right now.
Should we proceed? Yeah.
- [Audience Member] One last question.
Still not getting a hang of
it, to be honest, properly,
because more the content,
better the accuracy...
- [Dani] Right, so
you're storing everything
into Dynamo.
- Yes.
- [Dani] And then when
you have to get back,
you know, information,
you're getting back everything
that's from Dynamo, right?
- Correct.
- That dynamo would be
corresponding the
short-term memory, right?
But what the, first of all,
this is managed service, so you don't have
to focus on building a
memory storage solution.
We give that for you taking
care of infrastructure
scale and all the other things
that normally come with
managed services with AWS.
But then we don't stop there.
We don't stop at that
dynamo that you're building.
We are...
- They should come.
- Yeah. Sorry, just
- We'll explain the long
- Okay.
Yeah, I'll her explain it.
Yeah, I'll let it say what
comes after. (chuckles)
- [Akarsha] I think we will explain
with the long term of
what you're describing.
So maybe that that helps.
- It'll make sense.
- If not,
then we can take this question again.
- Yeah.
- Alright. Okay.
So based on how you've
configured the memory,
when you created the resource,
you can define one or more strategies
for smart insight extraction, right?
And you can say,
you can define one or
more of these strategies,
summary semantic or user
preferences or create your own.
And based on that it goes
through an extraction module.
Say it goes through an
extraction pipeline,
which essentially consists of two steps.
So one is the extraction step,
which is gonna look at
all the conversation
and extract only the relevant
piece of information.
So for example, if you're
talking about user preferences,
not everything that the user talks about
is talking about user preferences, right?
So from all of that context,
it's gonna only retrieve
wherever user mentions something
that they preferred,
they like, they dislike
or you know, whatever they prefer.
So it only extracts that information.
Now the second step in
this extraction module
is the consolidation step.
So now it looks at the
existing vector store.
So whatever memories it has
existing about that user,
it looks at those,
retrieves the most similar ones.
And it compares the new memories
that it has tried to create
and the existing memories.
And based on that, it consolidates that
and takes one of the steps.
So it either can add a new
memory into the vector store
or it can update an existing memory
with more complete piece of information.
Or the third one, if it's redundant,
if it's not adding any
new piece of information,
then it just skips it.
So this way we do not have any duplication
in the memory store that we create.
So once those memories are ready,
we save them into the
long-term memory store,
which essentially is a vector store
from which you can semantically retrieve
the similar memories
as in when the user asks something similar
from the agent.
So you can retrieve
the long-term memories,
which are more extracted insights,
but you can also retrieve the raw events.
So you can list, let's
say the last five messages
from that particular session,
plus perhaps the summary of that session
to compress the context
so that we do not have to deal
with the entire conversation window,
sorry, the entire context window
so we can make our agent more, more...
- Aware.
- Yes. (chuckles)
- Speaking to.
= [Akarsha] Alright, so how do we do that?
So with Strands, first of all,
we create a memory manager,
which provides us with
the control plane API,
where we can call get or create memory
and we provide in a name of the memory
and the strategy that we wanna create.
So these strategies, we don't
always have to provide one,
but we can provide
no or more strategies
that we can add in here.
So it takes in a list of a dictionary,
which takes in what type,
what strategy type do you wanna define,
what namespace do you wanna have?
So namespace in this case
is gonna take in a pot like structure,
which allows you to create that separation
of concern in the long term.
So in short term, we did that by actor ID
and session ID,
in long term, we are gonna
do that by name spaces.
So here, based on, you know, how do you,
how granular or how global do
you want your memories to be?
You can define a longer
path with more variables.
So you can add one, yeah, you can add zero
or more of these variables.
So you can add actor ID,
you can add a strategy ID
or you can add a session ID as well.
So based on that, it'll create a path
for you which you can then retrieve from.
- [Dani] So basically
instead of just having
a very big vector database
where you just throw in the new memories
that are being generated automatically,
you're able to create your own separation.
You know, you create your own structure
and how you're saving those memories
so that when you have to go
and retrieve those memories,
you have it in a logical way.
- [Akarsha] Yeah, and then you can define
also an event expiry day,
which defines how long
do you want the short-term memory to stay?
And that's, so in this
case it can be anything
between seven days to 365 days
and then you call that
API that returns you back
with a memory ID, right?
So this memory ID now
you can store somewhere
and kind of use it to
every time you wanna store
the memory information for your users.
So it takes on about one to two minutes.
- [Dani] Yeah, imagine
you'll have your agent
and you will have your, you know,
you have your agent
and you have your memory resource.
That agent will have to write
those events to those memory,
to that memory resource, right?
So you have that memory
id, you have your actor ID
and you have your session ID
and you just have to send information
over to AgentCore Memory.
- Exactly.
- And,
I won't say anything else.
- Okay. (chuckles) You should, you should.
(Dani chuckling)
All right, so how do we add
that to the agent, right?
So we have created a memory resource.
Now how do we write to that?
So first approach was a tool
approach that we saw for RAG.
The second approach
that I was talking about was hooks, right?
Here we are taking control
of different parts of the agent lifecycle.
So how it does is it enables us to write
or to take an action at different points
off the agent lifecycle.
Meaning I can define that
whenever the agent is
initialized, for example,
run a certain action, right?
So that will, I can hook something
in that part of the agent lifecycle.
So I can say every time
the agent is initialized,
call the agent initialized event, right?
Similarly, whenever the
user sends a request,
call the message at an event.
So this is then another
hook that you can add.
So we are gonna use this
capability, which, you know,
you can hook at different points in time.
So when the tool is being called
or when the request ends, so
when the agent responds back.
So we are gonna use two of these hooks
to create and to add our memory
and to retrieve from our memory.
So how does it look like?
So what we do here is first of all,
whenever the agent is being initialized,
we are asking our agent
to retrieve the user preferences
from the long-term memory.
So every time the agent is initialized,
we essentially load a profile of the user
to know what their preferences are, right?
And then every time a
new message is added,
we are storing the
message that the user sent
and also the messages
that the agent has sent
to our short-term memory.
Now behind the scenes
it should automatically
propagate to long-term memory.
So you don't have to do anything there,
but that's how we'll do.
And the second aspect was
we already created a tool
for the session data retrieval,
which was a RAG aspect.
So that's what we are doing
for retrieving the event
information from knowledge base.
So now let's see that.
So here we are creating a class
called memory hook provider,
which inherits from
the hook provider class
provided by Strands Agents.
So here what we do is we're
defining mainly two functions.
One is on agent initialized.
So here I say that
whenever the agent is initialized,
search the long-term
memories from this namespace.
So this was a namespace that I defined
when I created the memory.
and with this query,
so this way it can find
similar information.
So I already like hard code that hey,
give me the user preferences,
interests and background
so that I can personalize
my agent based on that.
So give me five of those preferences.
And those preferences I will then load
and append into the messages.
And this way now my agent knows
or has some context about what
does the user prefer, right?
And the second event that I'm gonna add
is on the message added event.
So every time a new message is added,
be it tool message,
be it user message,
be it agent message,
anytime a new message
is added to the state,
it is gonna load the last message
and it's gonna add that message,
it's gonna add that message
into the memory session manager.
So it's gonna send it to AgentCore Memory
as a conversational message.
So it's gonna take in a message content,
which is gonna be the string, the question
or the content that the user provides.
And along with the message role.
So that's what we are
sending to short-term memory
for it to be processed for long term.
- [Audience Member] How does it parse
or differentiate the user preferences
versus the conversation (faintly speaks).
- [Akarsha] So this you have
to define, so for example,
here what we are doing is in this case,
we are adding it into
the system prompt, right?
The user preferences we are adding
in the system prompt.
You can add it as a new message as well.
And there you can write like literally
in a string message,
you can say these are my user preferences.
So it cannot literally separate between,
oh this is memory or
this is a user message.
But you have to define that,
on how you want to send it to the agent.
- [Dani] A nice thing about this
is that we give you the tools
and we give you the flexibility
on using those tools
for your use case, right?
- Yeah.
Every, I'm pretty sure everyone,
everyone here has a different use case
and they're gonna be able
to interact with memory
in a different way
than the person that's
sitting next to you, right?
- [Audience Member] There's
a lot of sensitive data.
- Yeah.
- Customer data,
talk privacy section (faintly speaks).
- [Dani] So are you worried
that some people have access
to other people's information?
- Yeah.
- We'll get to that.
We'll get to that, yeah.
- [Audience Member]
(faintly speaks) Preferences
in their sessions.
- [Dani] So right now,
when you're sending messages
to the short-term memory,
you're defining an actor ID
and a session ID, right?
So with that actor id, you can
actually define who is that,
who does that event belong to, right?
So you have that logical
separation in that way.
And also you have IAM policies
that you can apply which
contain conditions.
So then you can give, you
know, permissions to an agent
to only access a memory resource
if the actor ID is corresponding
to whatever you say, right?
So you have multiple ways of securities,
but I'll cover it later.
- [Akarsha] Alright, so now
we have created the hooks
and now the only thing we have to do
is to register those hooks
with the hook registry
so that the agent knows
that these are the callbacks
that I have to do every
time an agent is initialized
or a message is added, right?
So you add that into the hook registry.
So now that is done.
So we have now a way to
call our memory, right?
And we've also already defined a way
to call our knowledge base.
So now we are gonna initialize the class
for the hook provider
and you're gonna add that to the agent.
So we have defined the memory hooks
and we are gonna add that to the agent
along with the tool that we created
for searching the re:Invent sessions
for the knowledge base, right?
And on top of that, we provide a state.
So this is where we are giving it
in a more deterministic way.
We are giving it the actor
ID and the session ID.
So this ideally should
come from the application.
Once the user has been authenticated,
you get the user information
from that session
and provide the actor ID based on that.
And similarly create a new session ID
or get it from whichever
environment it's running in,
but that you pass in as a state.
So to make it more deterministic
and to make sure that
it's the same information
that is propagated within the agent.
- [Dani] Yeah, you
basically don't want to say
date to agent, hey,
this is the user, blah blah blah,
this is just certain blah blah blah.
Because it'll probably
hallucinate and evoke away, right?
You wanna pass that as part
of the application code.
- [Akarsha] Exactly.
Alright, so now we have the agent ready,
now we can test it, right?
So first thing we do is to
give it some information
because right now we
haven't talked to the agent,
so it doesn't know anything about me.
So I give some,
I see it in some information about myself,
saying my name is Alice,
I'm a software engineer at TechCorp.
And this ideally should be
loaded in a more gradual way.
So when you are actually
building an application,
this will be built over time, right?
But in this case, for demo purposes,
we are kind of loading
in information at once.
So now we send that event,
we call the agent with this information
and the agent responds us back with,
okay, you know, thank
nice to meet you Alice,
thank you for telling me about yourself.
And then behind the
scenes using the hooks,
it should be able to store
that information in the short-term memory.
And then roundabout 30 seconds later,
it should also be available in
the long-term memory, right?
So the next time
we are calling the
long-term memory records,
we should be able to see
what we have already fed in.
So if we list
now the long-term memory records
from that certain prefix,
it should be able to retrieve
certain our preferences
that we just sent in.
So now the interesting thing to note here
is it not just stores the preference,
but it also stores the context
how it extracted that preference.
So it says the context is that
the user explicitly stated
that they work as a software
engineer at Tech Corp.
And that's why I extracted
the preference that
they work as a software engineer.
So it kind of defines a more explicit,
defines more proper reason
of why this preference has been extracted.
And based on that it also
creates a preference.
And now you can use this
information across sessions.
So if you create a new
agent with a new session ID,
- Same actor
- With the same actor,
but different session ID,
you are able to retrieve
the same information
about the actor
and you're able to use
it within the question.
So I asked this question saying,
"Hey, which sessions should I
attend at re:Invent," right?
And I already mentioned
that I'm interested in AI and security,
so it responds me back with,
based on it, "I'm happy to help you
with the perfect re:Invent session.
And based on your profile,
I can see you're interested
in cloud architecture, AI, and security,
and that you prefer
hands-on technical sessions.
So let me give you some sessions," right?
So based on that it gives me,
it searches the re:Invent sessions
and gives me that based on your interest.
These are the top
recommendations that I'll say.
So it gives me some GenAI,
some cloud operations
and some security recommendations, right?
So it makes it more personalized for me
of what I'm interested in,
what's my profile and
based on that it response.
So now we know that our memory is working,
let's move to runtime, right?
So what, I mean we now
have the agent running
in our local environment,
how do we move this to production?
So we need something
that is giving us a
session level isolation
because as you said, we are dealing
with user data here, right?
So we have to be highly vigilant
on how we are deploying this.
So the session not just has to be isolated
on the compute level,
but on the memory and the storage level.
So this provides us,
AgentCore runtime provides us
with true session isolation,
so with the compute memory and storage.
And it provides us with a fully
enterprise ready production workload,
workload ready system.
And it is automatically scalable.
So it's a serverless setup
which allows us to run hundreds
of sessions in a parallel manner.
So now how do we add this
to the solution, right?
So we had the endpoint that we created.
So everything else remains the same.
We are gonna deploy this to
AgentCore runtime, right?
So this is gonna be our way
to run this in production.
So how does that work?
So first of all,
what we have created right now
is we have an agent with
any model, any framework.
So we chose our bets.
But you can bring in
any model, any framework
of your preference.
And then what we are gonna
do is to create two endpoints
for Ping and for invocations.
Ping, we use for health checks
and invocations, we would use to know
where the entry point is.
So how do I invoke.
And then we add a requirements
file which defines
what dependencies do we have to install.
Now that will be what defines our agent.
So the first thing we have
to do is to deploy that
or to push that in a more packaged way
to the ECR.
So ECR, once we have
pushed the code to ECR,
we will have our container image ready
and we will provide some
more configurations.
Like we will provide the protocol settings
like which protocol do I wanna use?
HTTP, A-A, MCP,
how do I want to configure that agent.
And we provide some network settings
and that's what completes
our configuration set up.
Now once we have that,
they're gonna deploy that
to agent for runtime.
and then we have our agent
ready for invocation.
So then we can, in a concurrent way,
we can invoke multiple sessions
from the application that we build.
- [Dani] And it's session is a micro VM
that spins up,
loads that agent code and you have a user
that's gonna be interacting with
that specific agent here, session ID.
And when that session finishes,
the micro VM gets shut down
and everything gets deleted.
So that's why we have
to persist the information somewhere else
because when the AgentCore
runtime session finishes,
the context that the agent has is gone.
- [Akarsha] Yeah. Alright,
so how do we prepare it
for AgentCore runtime?
How do we prepare the agent
that we created right now
to deploy it on agent core runtime?
So we literally have to add
four extra lines of code.
So accept the structuring of the code,
we have to add four lines to
make it ready for runtime.
So first thing we add
is importing the AgentCore
application, right?
And the second thing,
we initialize the app.
Now the rest of the code is more about,
it's the same things
that we already created in
the notebook previously.
So we created a hook provider,
we created a tool for searching
the re:Invent session.
We create an initialized agent,
which is doing the exact
same thing as we did above.
So it's importing the tools, hooks,
and adding the actor
ID, session ID, state.
So we just package it into a function
and then we create a entry point.
So this is the line number three
of the code that we have to add.
So we add, we create
this decorator to define
that this is gonna be the
entry point of the application.
And here we've taken a payload
of whatever the user passes in,
from the application from the front end.
So that takes it, that
let's say gets in a prompt
and the actual ID,
which is gonna be done
after authentication.
And then that is what goes
in initializes the agent.
Takes the user input and
gives a response, right?
And then finally you have
to run the application.
So this is line number four.
So that is it.
So this is what you have
to add to make it ready.
So essentially creating
something like a fast API server
that allows us to run this piece of code.
Then we create an execution role
and we are then we configure and launch.
So these are the two things
we have to do to get it ready
as an endpoint that is
ready for consumption,
essentially for different users.
So we have this AgentCore starter toolkit
provides us with some tools to do that.
So we have a .configure.
So first of all, we
configure the application
with an execution role.
We allow it to auto create the ECR,
provide a requirements file
and ask it to take in the agent
and basically configure based on that.
Now once it has configured it,
it creates a docker file for you.
If you want to customize that,
you can create your own docker file
or you can also provide your own endpoint
from a different registry essentially.
Then once you have that,
then you can call .launch,
which is gonna launch the application
and put it for you to warm start, right?
And here you can also provide
some environment variables
which takes in your memory ID,
knowledge base ID, model ID and region.
And now we have it up and running.
So this will take around
about a couple of minutes
for you to get started.
So now I think the only
thing missing here, Dani,
is the identity.
- Yeah.
- Do you wanna add?
- [Dani] So just show
the small location to see
how it looks like.
- Okay,
- Yeah.
- [Akarsha] Makes sense.
- [Dani] So basically we just
pass from our local notebook,
(indistinct) POC working,
we route our managers
and now we need to get this
into production, right?
So that's where we use AgentCore runtime.
We pass from a notebook
to actually having our agents
running at scale securely.
And you wanna show the how
the location looks like.
You can see there it's says
agentcore.runtime.invoke.
I'm passing in my prompt,
"what sessions would you recommend?"
And in this case, I'm
passing my actor ID, right?
This remember right now is hardcoded,
the goal is not to have this hardcoded,
it should actually know
who the actor is based on our login, okay?
So if you see there, will, yeah.
- [Akarsha] So we ask the same question,
what sessions would you recommend?
- [Dani] Exactly. And I already, or-
- [Akarsha] Personalized
recommendations to us.
- [Dani] Yeah, okay.
So that's basically our agent running
in AgentCore runtime.
Last bit of the architecture
is identity, right?
So here's where we use AgentCore identity,
how is this gonna help us?
But initially we're gonna have our user,
which interacts with
our application, right?
First step, our user logs into application
using our IDP of choice, right?
We support multiple IDPs, right?
Our user logs in, gets back
an IP token from that IDP
and then I can go and invoke
AgentCore runtime, right?
So to that call that Akarsha had before,
I will have a new variable
that will say they were token, right?
And there I will include their IDP token
that I got back from my IDP.
Now, thanks to AgentCore
identity inbound authentication.
So basically it determines who the user is
and if it's allowed to call the agent
every time we call AgentCore runtime,
before it's actually just invocation,
it will go call AgentCore identity.
Identity will go back to the IDP
and validate that IDP token, okay?
And if that's valid it will say,
"Hey, you're allowed to go
ahead and do that invocation."
Okay, pretty simple steps here.
So how does that change at the code level?
When we are doing in the
AgentCore runtime configuration,
we are gonna add two different things.
One is the authorized configuration.
That's where we are
configuring our JWT authorizer.
In this case I'm using Cognito.
So I'm passing in my discovery URL
and my allowed clients, right?
And also very important bit here
is my request header allow list.
And what I'm doing here
is that I'm allowing
AgentCore runtime to propagate
to the AgentCore, the
authorization token, right?
So what's gonna happen
next inside the agent,
if I show this here,
is that when my user locks it, huh?
- It's here.
- Okay.
When my user log into the application,
it will retrieve
that identity token from Cognito.
It will do the agent invocation passing in
that Cognito identity token
and from inside the
agent I'm calling Cognito
with that token to retrieve
the user information, right?
And that's what the
Akarsha is showing there.
- So the same code that I showed before,
it's exact same functionality.
The only thing that different
is instead of passing
the actual ID directly,
we are getting the user identity
from the authorization header.
So this is what is being propagated
from the AgentCore runtime.
And this is being authorized
from AgentCore identity
by Cognito.
- [Dani] Exactly.
So no more hard coding
either sessions or actor ID.
That ID is coming straight
from the identity token
from Cognito,
session ID, we're using the same session
that AgentCore runtime is running, right?
So as you remember before
it works with sessions.
Each session is a micro VM that's one up,
loads the (indistinct) code
and runs that session has an ID
and that's what we are using as an ID
for our session inside
AgentCore memory, right?
And I think...
- That is it,
- Four minutes left.
That's it, and... (chuckles)
- [Akarsha] Exactly what Dani showed,
- Yeah.
- on the screen,
so when we are configuring it,
we added these two
configuration for JWT authorizer
and the header configurations.
So we have them here
that allows it to know
what is the discovery URL
from where to authorize from
and what would be the client ID.
So what would be the
allowed clients for me.
And that is it.
Keeps it track.
- So lemme just go back to my,
- [Akarsha] We have five
minutes to take this.
- [Dani] Yeah. Resources and questions.
Put your resources here.
We have some authentic AI
resources to get started.
Agentic AI.
We have GitHub, Bedrock,
AgentCore samples.
We'll be pushing the
code that we saw today,
this week there.
So if you go to GitHub
and say Amazon Bedrock AgentCore
samples on their memory,
it should be there.
And yeah, follow me on LinkedIn
and Akarsha will probably
post it there also.
Very important,
please complete the session survey.
Five stars recommended, other optional.
And yeah, (chuckles)
I'll take any questions now.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.